michael a reçu ce pokémon evoli pour
noël mais impossible de le faire
fonctionner et le problème ne se pose de
trouver les piles faisant fonctionner ce
pokémon car aucun panneau ne vous dit
que c'est d'api l'appareil photo vous
trouvez ces piles aussi juste à côté
alors si quelqu'un peut faire entrer une
pile comme ceux ci le dense et très bien
moi je n'y arrive pas l'appui le calibre
inférieur rentre effectivement mais on
ne peut pas refermé le pokémon
le vin a bien essayé de brancher les
piles entre elles avec un fil de cuivre
mais côté pratique on a déjà vu mieux
alors je vais vous dire fou est inventif
non non il veut pas aujourd'hui il ya
pourtant on n'arrête pas il avait la
tête à bout sa tête soyez faut secouer
un peu les piles
c'est enfin bon je peux pas me voir
faire ça mais trois enfants pendant une
journée à 28
jean michel est ensuite parti en quête
des fameux fil lrv rouyn de grande
surface en moins de surface mais sans
succès le sauveur sur un buraliste
spécialisé dans les pigs en tout genre
ça y est vous les trouvez oui enfin
depuis hier après midi
ici j'avais eu un petit doute de les
trouver ici quand même parce qu'il faut
plusieurs sortes de piles et j'ai trouvé
à 40 francs les deux piles ciré dia pro
fonctionnaires un jouet de 60 francs 70
francs il faut 40 points de piles des
fils qui peuvent plus de la moitié du
prix du jouet une surprise difficile à
digérer pour jean-michel enfin evoli a
quand même prévu